- [Voiceover] Warning!
Fiercely caffeinated, highly addictive.
World's strongest coffee.
Today we found eight people
who have a death wish!
- World's strongest coffee.
That's totally bull--
- Are you gonna wish
you died or it's what's
gonna make you die?
- Are they implying it's
enough caffeine to kill you?
- [Voiceover] Just how
strong is this coffee?
We took one mg of caffeine
and substituted it for
one tablespoon of Death
Wish grounds so you
can actually see it.
The results:
(dramatic music)
- You can try all you
want, you're not gonna
make me afraid of beans.
- I hate coffee, the end.
- [Man] I like sugar.
- [Woman] Coffee flavored milk.
- Going to Taste Town.
- Oh wow, this is amazing!
- Just tastes like coffee.
- Notes of bones.
- And wood.
- Hellfire.
- Nails.
- Blood.
- That's what that taste
is, it's Viking blood.
- Wow, like I feel like
all my senses are like
elevated right now.
- I'm drinking it without milk and I can
drink this whole cup.
- My heart is definitely
beating really fast right now.
- I would wish Death coffee on anybody.
- Oh, is this gonna give us diarrhea?
- I'm home after work after
having two cups of it.
I felt a lot of energy
running through my hands.
- I'm here in the bathroom
and things are moving along
really well and urgently.
- It's around midnight
and I cannot fall asleep.
- I usually like need two
or three cups of coffee to
even really feel it.
I'm definitely awake.
- [Man] More Death Wish
coffee please, now!
How many times do I have to say it?
- [Woman] Garret's pumped up!